quién se queda quién se va la llegada
del consejo de ministros el jueves fue
una oportunidad para hacer predicciones
sobre la composición del próximo
gobierno en cualquier caso los actuales
miembros deberán servir presentes la
próxima semana ya que en el primer
quinquenio de manuel ma con no termina
oficialmente hasta el 14 de mayo
el gobierno está en su tarea de seguir
tomando las decisiones necesarias para
la protección de los franceses y de
todos los temas de actualidad
sin embargo el nombramiento de un nuevo
primer ministro cambiará la situación se
especula sobre quién será el sucesor de
jan castex la personalidad elegida
deberá dar el impulso deseado por macrón
de cara a las elecciones legislativas de
junio mientras tanto la consigna sigue
siendo la misma desde la victoria del
presidente saliente el pasado domingo
la elección de los franceses que es una
elección histórica es una elección que
nos obliga y requiere que se tomen
decisiones importantes sobre el fondo
pero también sobre una nueva forma de
gobernar de implicar a los franceses en
la decisión de dar vida a la ciudad
la política prometida en 2017 estaría
por tanto a punto de aplicar se podría
comenzar durante la primera quincena de
mayo cuando se espera tenga lugar la
ceremonia de investidura presidencial